e tal vou começar cantando uma música um
trechinho que marca bem quem eu sou aqui
dentro dessa academia
quem é você que já quer ser doutor negou
abusado do rabo empinado quem foi que
mandou ninguém mandou na verdade eu
venho de uma família pobre sua terceira
pessoa da minha família a conseguir
entrar numa universidade e foi essa né
hoje eu já vi outros palestrantes
falando que a gente tem afinidade de
percurso entrar na ufrj na década de 90
ainda era também um um lugar muito
especial eu não tinha essa ideia disse
eu queria fazer universidade
eu não sabia que era tão especial está
na universidade pública mas é assim
infelizmente eu chegar aqui eu vou
precisar contar um pouco da minha
história para poder depois dizer o
porquê da universidade que eu desejo
para o futuro e para os nossos filhos
e aí quando eu cheguei que não fui bem
ser bem recebida como eu imaginava assim
era uma universidade popó tomo sabe se
lenta é segredo que segregava muitas
vezes me sentir discriminado por ser uma
aluna negra e pobre
e foi assim foi um período muito ruim
porque você faz um é uma saga né
a gente entra na universidade pré
vestibular e os pais da gente faz em um
sacrifício para que a gente possa fazer
o pré vestibular
eu já tinha vindo de umas de uma
experiência também fracassada na gama
filho
primeiro por conta do valor que foi
ficando meio difícil de dar conta lá em
casa e era faculdade de direito e quando
eu cheguei lá eu vi que eu queria uma
coisa criativa e eu não conseguia achar
isso no direito e aí eu fui na oea e não
dava pra pagar e era um estresse tão
grande que me é que a cena final do mês
sair da gama com uma dívida
e aí resolvi entrar no pré-vestibular
pedir essa segunda chance à família e
consegui passar pra ler atrás aqui no
fundão e aí fui muito bem
impressionante assim não conseguir
encontrar pares sabe acha que o é e eu
escrevi a queria ser escritora aí ea
universidade também é minha pagando isso
assim a sensação que eu tive quando eu
cheguei na letra que eu não sabia nada e
aí foi deste tipo deixando de escrever
foi um período bem difícil e um dia
andando pelos corredores da universidade
eu vi um grupo de pessoas negras che se
apresentando teatralmente no corredor eu
fiquei congelado imagino não é precária
todo mundo igual a mim e todos de branco
com mais uma coisa assim
bata com os amarrados e quando acabou
assim muito emocionada ao falar com o
diretor eu quero fazer parte eu quero
seguir vocês não quero perder nunca mais
e ali foi a minha grande salvação porque
eu até aprendi esses dias aqui com o
pessoal do ted que o hack a universidad
hardy esse grupo me trouxe
é um posicionamento crítico sobre o que
eu estava vivendo vivem andando da
universidade até porque a gente ficava
meio receoso de achacar acho que aquele
professor está me discriminando era uma
coisa que não se falava muito mas que
tinha muito e eu encontrei esses pares
que viviam nessas situações em outras
universidades
esse grupo se chamava sendo 1 e era um
grupo que era tinha uma projeção no
estado e tinha uma projeção nacional
também a gente até chegou a ter um ou
dois encontros na bahia e tinha umas
articulações que saíam do rio de janeiro
foi um grupo muito produtivo para o meu
pensamento político pra minha crítica
academia ea educação porque a gente
discutia muito isso a gente também
discutirá gênero ea gente estava no meio
assim ameaçado porque a gente não pensou
as cotas de que as cotas já tinham sido
pensadas por gerações antes da gente que
não conseguiram fazer com que elas
acontecessem ea gente tinha antes
são a gente buscava essas pessoas né que
que já vinham em décadas discutindo essa
questão de reparação começa a surgir
essa palavra né
nos meios de educação nos meios de arte
e cultura é que tinha uma história ser
reparado com os negros no nosso país
ainda continua talvez a gente ainda tem
que novamente pegar velhas armas plena
pra gente conseguir avançar
e aí eu esse grupo foi me dando o chão
era um grupo muito articulado a gente
era um núcleo do centro de teatro do
oprimido que era dirigido pelo augusto
boal então esse era um teatro político
era um teatro de atitude e isso é vai me
impulsionar para a educação de uma
maneira que eu não voltar nunca mais só
que nesse percurso eu eu conheço o
instituto de arte tea e começa a fazer
os cursos de lá desenvolver e estou há
20 anos nessa instituição
passei por todos os cursos trabalho em
todo tipo de projeto hoje o coordenador
dos projetos de mediação a isso foi
muito importante pra mim porque com essa
decepção da academia teve uma hora que
eu desistir
olha é não faz nenhum sentido pra mim
essa via crucis depois de você passar no
vestibular
você chega numa curva em uma academia
que na década de 90 não tinha tantas
possibilidades de bolsa tinha umas
pesquisas mas aí era só por um grupo
muito seleto que a gente não conseguiu
alcançar
e aí eu resolvi abandonar a filha não
quer não acredito que a educação seja
assim muito impulsionada pela
experiência com a cultura da infância no
tear afetiva acolhedora sabe aquela
aquela é um processo que a gente passa
pelo olhar porque você viveu também ele
não só acredito news
e aí sair da universidade
participei de muitas instituições fui
ajudei a fundar o afroreggae passe por
um senhor muito
muitas mesmo como arte-educadora às
vezes como incentivadora como uma pessoa
pra colaborar para somar nos processos e
estava muito bem obrigado
trabalhava numa instituição é que na
maré
eu trabalhei durante 11 anos a redes da
maré e aí uma coordenadora lá falou
assim para mim olha eu quero que hoje
você vá na praia vermelha porque está
iniciando um projeto lá muito bacana e
eu quero que a rede tem uma participação
e fui quem sabe muito bem que que era
nenhum nome do projeto eu sabia quando
eu cheguei lá e só 2009 era a
universidade das quebradas e é um
projeto criado pela luiza bairros de
holanda em uma ciro e eu fiquei
completamente apaixonada em 2009 a helô
ea numa juntaram ao longo do ano inteiro
intelectuais de diversas áreas artistas
produtores culturais a galera da
periferia da periferia do rio de janeiro
foi a primeira vez que ouvi falar
periferia do brasil não imaginava isso
mas existe uma periferia no brasil né e
professores internacionais quando tinha
algum professor aqui na na universidade
dando sopa que a helô conhecia ela
levava para discutir e aí a gente pensou
como seria
as quebradas em 2010 a gente tem ou a
primeira turma de quebradeiras que eu
fiz parte né
e como eu sou uma das mais antigas lá
hoje eu sou mestre quebradeira é eu
incrível gente precisa conhecer a
universidade se quebradas ela funciona
hoje aqui no prédio da letras dentro do
pac que é um programa de pós-graduação
programa de aceleração de cultura
contemporânea e hoje nós estamos
instalados aqui se está conseguindo
organizar melhor a nossa a nossa o nosso
espaço aqui dentro da da ufrj e assim
pra mim foi muito marcante eu escolhi
esse momento pra pra poder antecipar é o
que eu mais digno de uma universidade do
futuro para a minha filha adora porque a
universidade
quebrada está muito perto disso né é foi
muito emocionante para mim poder voltar
pra academia eu me lembro que nem se dê
no primeiro dia que eu cheguei lá o que
nessa reunião
e aí me apresentar aloulou vendeu um
abraço e você já imagina na década até
intelectual fantástico que vem
nossa você é a cara das quebradas eu
fiquei assim explicar isso para dentro
da academia mesmo desconfiei
num primeiro momento por que não fazer
relação com nada do que eu já tinha
vivido aqui dentro
e realmente é é eu abracei esse projeto
hoje eu sou assistente da coordenação
geral é a gente ajuda no processo do do
programa mas a gente tem uma
universidade ela muito orgânica então
qualquer aluno é um curso de extensão
então qualquer pessoa que faça parte do
curso pode tá nas reuniões a gente pelo
menos duas vezes por mês a gente se
reúne com o grupo no mesmo e todo mundo
fala diretamente para a coordenação que
quer o que deseja
se o programa tá legal se precisa é
enxugar em algum lugar se está fazendo
referência à nau e é essa universidade
que eu acredito uma universidade
acolhedora né que escute a as
necessidades que a gente tem e isso a
gente não pode é expressivo evento é
maravilhoso a gente não pode deixar de
entender que isso é uma escolha política
né
eu já ouvi aqui outros palestrantes
falarem da de da diversidade que precisa
ter né de gerenciar melhor os recursos
que chegam pra para a universidade e que
eles cheguem na graduação eu acredito
que a gente precise ter uma educação de
afeto em qualquer fase da vida a gente
tem é esse princípio lá no ceará a gente
tem cursos de formação para adultos
professores ea gente conta a história a
gente brinca
não é porque você fez seis anos e
aprendeu a lei que ninguém precisa mais
ler uma história pra você você não
precisa ouvir uma história de alguém
é o que eu queria fazer com uma marca
essa é essa universidade que o sonho
para a dora que a minha filha está há 15
anos que eu sempre os meus netos que eu
sou o filho de todo mundo uma
universidade que a gente apague o pré
vestibular eo vestibular sabe uma
universidade que a gente não precisa ter
cotas porque você nasceu e você nasce
com o direito de ter uma formação do
maternal da educação infantil até a
universidade aonde quer que você queira
chegar eu acho que a gente está neste
momento saber de pensar que a gente não
precisa é na formação e educação direito
de todos é um direito de todos até no
último legado que cada um queria chegar
a sensação que eu tenho hoje é que muita
coisa já avançou existia esse espaço
aqui me deixa muito feliz com uma galera
incrível que vai me atualizando acho que
o f5 é que atualiza o computador foi
moto quando eu cheguei aqui no ted de
entender como é que eu construir né ô ô
ô meu processo de hackear porque toda
vez eu eu fiquei com raiva da
universidade mas toda vez que tinha uma
coisa muito legal eu ia lá tu vai fazer
esse curso eu já sabia onde era a porta
de entrada
então eu fui fazendo várias coisas mesmo
que não quisesse mesmo escondidinho
ouvinte mas eu sempre bati na porta e
falar eu achei legal posso fazer e aí eu
acho que consegui fazer uma formação
autónoma llano nas quebradas eu falo
muito isso vamos abolir a educação
bancária
ninguém vai ficar só sentada olhando tem
uma hora que você vem dividir o seu
saber aqui com a gente a gente precisa
dessa troca
a gente precisa que você diga o que você
acha que é importante para a sua
formação
então é o que eu penso eu que a gente
nessa universidade do futuro
a gente precisa é ser gestor da educação
ela precisa ser orgânico ela tem que se
ater vida eu saí da universidade porque
eu não fazia paralelo com a minha vida
tinha já trabalhou em vários projetos
sociais tinha que atravessar
a cidade para chegar aqui e chegar numa
sala de aula de grego que falava por si
só mas o que é para fazer correndo da
florida
o professor copia haiti um quadro de
declinações em grego aquilo não fazia a
meo o menor sentido pra mim e aí eu me
distanciei eu estou falando isso em
voltando um pouco nisso porque durante
algum tempo eu carreguei uma culpa era
eu que não conseguia dar conta da
universidade mas a universidade das
quebradas me mostrou que não quer a
universidade que era muito pequena para
helmes premialy dentro então acho que
ela já ampliou a gente conseguiu avançar
em algumas coisas mas a gente ainda tem
muito por avançar muito e eu acho que a
extensão é um dos pilares da
universidade mas ainda é aquela é aquele
filho menor que ninguém dá muita atenção
à pesquisa e à graduação elas ea
formação acadêmica estão muito à frente
da extensão ea extensão é um lugar de
socialização ao lugar que o cara que já
tentou mil vezes às vezes lá nas
quebradas a gente veio sentar para a
universidade
muitas vezes a nossa educação pública
ela paz uma defasagem natural mas o cara
chega lá e ele tem muito saber porque
ele é o mestre de capoeira da comunidade
dele porque ele fundou um projeto social
de mulheres porque articula todo o
território dentro do rio de janeiro
mas academia não consegue ver isso como
saber na universidade assim na
universidade das quebradas isso é saber
a gente valoriza e a gente olha de igual
pra igual essa é a grande pesquisa que
ela propõe na nessa troca de saberes
entre a periferia e academia da ecologia
de saberes e é nesse lugar que eu
acredito para finalizar eu quero falar
de uma de uma citação do milton santos
que é um dos intelectuais que mais me
são caros né
e eu tive uma oportunidade nessa
militância nacional de encontrar com ele
junto com um grupo de universitários
negros em são paulo na usp e
e ele comentou algo nesse sentido que
depois de ouvir 11 dos últimos vídeos
deles na na internet que ele falava que
a universidade que a que a humanidade
ainda estava vivendo lampejos
civilizatórios é por um lado isso me
acolheu por que eu ficar então temos
muito trabalho adiante mas por outro
isso me atormenta sabe a gente não pode
voltar para trás
tem que ser daqui pra frente era isso
que eu tinha pra falar pra vocês
brigaram
[Aplausos]